hi guys today I'm gonna tell you why I
believe you should not strive to become
a perfectionist and take it from me
because I used to take lots of pride in
being a perfectionist ever since I can
remember I was striving to do my
absolute best in everything that I could
do putting in the extra work staying
behind work or class or whatever I was
doing being annoyed by the small
imperfections making sure that it was up
to extremely high standards that is how
I wanted to be seen by others that's how
I saw myself that's why I passed it all
of my CV and my website even to this day
I think people might still say that I am
a perfectionist but I no longer say it
anymore because I think that was one of
the biggest mistakes that I've ever made
putting a label on myself that is
actually quite unattainable it's really
difficult to live up to such a label as
a perfectionist please don't get me
wrong I'm not saying that I'm not still
that same girl I'm not saying that I
won't still wet cards do long hours
because I take pride in what I do if I'm
doing something I'm usually doing it out
of passion and I do want it to be of a
certain standard but instead of saying
that I'm a perfectionist and this is a
perfectionist quality I usually just say
something along the lines of I'm an
enthusiastic hard worker
because that is more accurate the
reality of the situation is that
perfection is unattainable it is not
real you cannot reach those standards
and it's probably some of you shaking
your heads right now being like what are
you talking about of course of course
you can and you should always strive to
and even if it is unattainable
you should still be trying to get it and
if you can be of that mindset where you
realize you're trying to reach 110
percent however that's not attainable so
if you get to 80 or 90 that's okay then
that's perfect if you can be that person
and not beat yourself up about not
actually reaching the perfection of the
title that you're giving yourself you
know cuz if you're saying you're a
perfectionist kind of means that you're
reaching perfection or that you're not
happy until you reach perfection however
pretty much unattainable to even reach
your own 100 percent standards let alone
everyone else's 100 percent standards as
well because perfection is subjective
everyone else has their own opinions of
what something perfect is so maybe
you'll create something or you'll do a
piece of whack and in one person's mind
it is absolutely a hundred and ten
percent don't have done it it's amazing
they love it another person will just be
like what is this I don't like it it's
not even 50% and you can't help the way
that they feel about what you've created
or made or or try to achieve it's just
their own personal opinion however to a
perfectionist that is a massive knock
back because what you might have thought
was perfection is now being told that
it's not so how do you change that thing
or how do you take on board that
criticism for next time to then reach
that one person's idea of perfection
that then might change how other people
perceive it the people who already like
it I
consents here basically is hard enough
to reach your own unattainable
expectations than to reach unexplainable
expectations of so many others as well
especially in this day and age where
pretty much everything that we do is
shared online to a global audience of
millions you cannot reach all of their
high expectations and if you're telling
everyone and you are expected to be a
perfectionist that's what they're going
to assume that you're going to create or
even if they're not assuming it you're
going to assume that they're already
assuming it because you're already
telling them that you're perfectionist
you know that that's their idea of you
because you've planted that in their
head and that's a lot of pressure to put
on yourself to be reaching perfection in
everything that you do no don't do that
to yourself it's difficult and when
you're a perfectionist you start to
think in absolutes which is detrimental
to your mental health please don't do
this
you start to think that unless it's
perfect
and at the best and highest quality and
standard and it's just not good enough
nothing you do is good enough unless it
is up there unless it is perfect and
less it is reaching the impossible it's
not even good enough you end up
crippling yourself you end up stifling
yourself because you can't do anything
because it's not going to reach that
unattainable perfection level what is
the point in that
surely you want to be making as much as
you can or doing as much you can
practicing as much you can I don't know
what you want to be perfect at and I'm
talking mainly in a career sense but I'm
gonna go on more in a second but surely
you want to be doing that and also so
that you can be progressing on what you
do getting feedback trying out new
things seeing what works seeing what
doesn't then just trying to make every
single thing that you do hit an
impossible barrier it just doesn't make
any sense you're gonna end up looking
lazy you're gonna end up looking like
you're not doing any work if that's what
you're worried about that is what you're
going to end up being seen as instead of
being seen as a hard-working
perfectionist
but and this isn't just inclusive to the
working world
if you develop this mindset of
perfectionism and thinking in absolutes
that's a very detrimental way of
thinking and it can kind of seep into
other rounds of your life it can become
overwhelming and the thoughts of being
perfect just kind of eats away at your
your personal life the things that you
should find fun your relationship with
your friends and family any closer
relationship with a singular person or
even the way that you look the way that
your body is shaped the way that your
your face appears everything needs to be
perfect
everything needs to live up to those
high expectations that you have been
giving yourself that you have been
living by the rules that you have set
yourself and that is when you realize
it's gotten too far being perfect is
impossible
I guess perhaps what's difficult about
being a perfectionist is once you allow
other people to imprint their ideas of
perfection onto you that's when you
start to really criticize yourself
that's when you start to really wonder
what you're doing and how you can
achieve what you thought was high
standards but now you're constantly
changing these all the time to appease
other people because essentially if
you're perfect are you doing it for
yourself or are you doing it to please
the world and
mankind around you because if you're
perfect then who does that help I mean
if there were no other people around to
judge you surely you're perfect already
right no one's gonna tell you otherwise
no one's gonna tell you whether your
work is good or bad no one's gonna give
you a grade on piece of paper no one is
going to tell you what your BMI should
be ultimately this was just a rants
trying to explain to you something that
I have taken far too many years to
realize we all want to be seen as
extraordinary something better something
more interesting some something more
intelligent whatever whatever you strive
to be you want to be seen as it you
don't want to be seen as your average
Joe but you're not
no one is everyone's different
everyone's got their own unique quirk
and a reason for someone to become
interested in them and if they're not
that's their problem but you can't be
perfect you can strive to be something
greater than what you are you're a
musician and you want to make a music
better you can strive for that that's
great if you are a filmmaker and you
want to become better audio for your
films do it but you can't be perfect you
only live once and if you're reaching
for things that you can never be in ants
you'll never be happy with who you are
and you'll never allow anyone else to
appreciate you
either you'll always be questioning how
to how to get better
never just appreciating what's already
there and what you can already do so
yeah please don't be a perfectionist
just just don't do it be an enthusiastic
hard worker
okay I believe in you you can do what
you want to do but don't push yourself
too hard
have fun with it as well if you're not
having fun there is no print in anything
before we go I just want to quickly say
a massive thank you to all of my patreon
I've been going through a lot with their
University and you know this you can
kind of guess from the video just
feeling like it why do is I'm good
enough of whatever and you guys been
helping me on my my discord chat and
things like that and yeah just you're
the best thank you so much
I mean everyone who watches these videos
are amazing I really appreciate just all
all the support I get I need to stop
being so silly and just to have more fun
with my videos so anyway I won't say a
massive massive thank you to you all you
have been amazing
thank you I hope you stick around but
Thomas will gush it when I say mr.
Thomas blame Jewish started saying it
Kevin VanDam toward image tomorrow
Danielle Ben um class she's blonde
salvatore Mayer fields August MP and she
loves and Yvonne je veux main role
either for Burlinson
Wayne Wells and James heck yeah because
I don't know if I should keep fighting
because I feel like I have just
butchered everyone's names I'm trying to
say thank you sorry sorry thanks for
letting me have a round I've literally
dare evening by